bienvenidos a el nivel número dos en
suma vamos a hacer nuevos niveles si
ustedes ya aprendieron a hacer sumas de
un solo dígito pero esto se pone más
interesante y ahora haremos sumas con
dos dígitos
ok seguramente ya comprendiste la parte
básica y poco a poco dominará sexto
cuantos 11 más 4 lo que haremos es tomar
las primeras cifras que están pegadas
del lado derecho y columna por columna
la sumaremos así es que hagámoslo 1 + 4
es igual a 5
entonces colocaremos aquí el número 5 y
veremos que 1 + 0 porque aquí está
completamente vacío 1 0 es igual a 1
así es que 11 + 4 es igual a 15 si no me
crees lo podemos hacer de otra forma
veamos recuerdan que la vez pasada
hicimos dos mecanismos distintos uno es
el de contar y el otro es el de la línea
de números
normalmente no les recomiendo de estar
contando de uno en uno para números
grandes porque les tomará para siempre
sin embargo muchas veces vale la pena
tomarse el tiempo y mantener la
respuesta correcta contemos con el que
tengo 11 pelotas azules 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 11 pelotas azules y tú me
regalas 4 más 1 2 3 4 estas son las 11
pelotas azules que yo tenía
originalmente más las 4 que tú me estás
dando tomaremos otro color y con ella
contaremos así es que empecemos 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 es
exactamente el mismo resultado que ya
teníamos les comentaba que también
estaba la forma de hacerlo vía la línea
de números así es que haré una línea en
la que acomodar de uno en uno los
números aquí empezaré en cero y digamos
que es 1
2 3 4 5 6
11 12 13 14 15 16 17 y así podemos
seguir estas flechas lo que indican es
que este número puede incrementarse
hasta 100 miles cientos de miles
millones trillones lo que ustedes gusten
e incluso aprenderemos más adelante que
hay números más allá del cero esta
flecha indica eso regresamos a nuestro
ejercicio original
estábamos en 11 nos colocamos en 11 y
sumaremos 4 sumar significa que
aumentaremos ese 11 en 4 entonces iremos
1 2 3 4
y volvimos a llegar al 15 entonces
nuestra respuesta fue adecuada vamos a
hacer operaciones un poco más
complicadas ustedes ya pueden dominar
esto sin problemas
cuánto será ahora 28 más 7
ya saben qué haremos tomaremos la
primera columna por lo que 87 es igual a
ustedes lo pueden verificar por línea de
números o por contar en este caso
sabemos que 87 es igual a 15 por lo que
este 5 lo tomaremos y lo colocaremos
dentro de la columna que estamos
trabajando vamos a cambiar el color este
5 quedará aquí y este 1 corresponde a
las decenas lo llevaremos o lo
arrastraremos para tener nuestro número
15 dividida en unidades y decenas este 1
lo que indica realmente son 10 10 más 5
son 15 ahora haremos la suma de la
siguiente columna 1 + 2 es igual a 3
por lo tanto 28 7 es igual a 35
y esto tiene sentido veamos por qué no
pueden pensar de la siguiente manera
ahora sabemos que 87 es igual a 15 si
aumentamos un 10 18 7 es igual a 25 28 7
es igual a 35 38 más 7 es igual a 45
alcanzan a ver el patrón que estamos
repitiendo una forma más en la que
podemos imaginar esto es si yo tengo 28
más 1
esto será 29 entonces 28 más 2 será 30
más 3
será 31 40 32 más 50 33 más 6 será 34 y
más 7 será 35
vamos bien qué tal que ahora hacemos una
suma mucho más complicada que las que
hemos estado manejando cuántos eran 99
más 9
veamos 99 + 9 hagamos exactamente lo
mismo que hemos estado haciendo
cambiemos el color para que sea más
divertido 9 + 9 será igual a 18 haremos
lo mismo que con los ejercicios pasados
este 8 lo colocaremos en la columna que
estamos trabajando mientras que el 1 lo
arrastraremos hacia la siguiente columna
para trabajarlo ahora trabajaremos las
decenas 1901 más 9 sabemos que es 10
como ya no tenemos absolutamente más
nada del lado izquierdo colocaremos el
10 completo cierto que ya estamos como
calentando ya tenemos práctica nos vamos
por uno más cuánto será esta vez 56
+ 7
veamos poco a poco se han complicado
bien sin embargo estamos teniendo todas
las posibilidades de hacerlo volvamos a
separar 67 es igual a 13 tomaremos este
3 y lo colocaremos en la columna que
estamos trabajando y arrastraremos el 1
correspondiente a las decenas
ahora sumaremos 15 es igual a 6 56 7 es
igual a 63 más adelante haremos sumas
con cifras muchísimo mayores sin embargo
en este momento lo importante es que
vean cuál es el patrón de seguimiento
para que podamos resolver operaciones
con números enormes nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo